elles ont échangé leur tenu de sport
contre des tenues de jardinage six
sportifes de haut niveau été présentes
ce dimanche 28 janvier au Golf National
de 50 ans en yine dans le cadre d'un
projet environnemental leur objectif
planter des arbres avec des jeunes pour
sensibiliser aux enjeux écologiques je
pense que c'est vraiment
important de jouer un rôle d'inspiration
pour pour les plus jeunes pour les
jeunes générations puis pour les gens en
général montrer que le sport aussi ê
vecteur aussi de de protection de
l'environnement de d'écologie et cetera
ça a du sens pour moi d'être dans cette
team capitain sport Planet parce que ça
uvre pour l'environnement ça montre en
fait les bon geste au quotidien ces
sportifes âgés de 23 à 55 ans ont passé
en moyenne 15 années en équipe de France
des profils variés et connu du grand
public qui ont séduit les responsables
du projet capitaine sport Planet porté
par l'assureur lamaïf ce sont des
personnes qui doivent être attractives
et passer un message auprès d'une large
communauté ce sont toutes des des
capitaines toutes discipline confondu
hein puisqu'on est à la fois sur
effectivement du du pentathlon la
natation on est sur également du basket
donc il y a il y a cette disciplines de
représenter donc c'est que tous les
sports sont concernés par ces
problématiques là et que tous les
athlètes quel que soit leur niveau de
compréhension des enjeux écologiques le
principal c'est d'avoir envie et c'était
vraiment le critère de sélection de
cette équipe au total 2024 arbres être
planté sur cette année dans le cadre de
ce projet ces athlètes vont maintenant
se concentrer sur les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 les sportifs se retrouveront
ensuite pour une ascension du Mont-Blanc
en septembre toujours sur la thématique
environnementale